hey everybody welcome to live-streaming
with Jessie and today is going to be
probably one of the shortest streams
that I've done since I first started so
I had something that was supposed to
happen at 5:00 and now it got bumped way
up to 3:30 and it would take me a little
while to drive there so that means we
have we got to be done pretty quickly so
if you've watched before you know
usually the streams go like at least an
hour and a half so what I it's gonna be
a little different than normal for
today's stream so I wanted to implement
some material design tabs and like this
I thought it was going to take me a lot
longer than that really did so since I
knew it had to be a short stream I
started working on it before the stream
and thinking that I could get some of it
out of the way and then just finish it
up and I ended up getting it finished so
what I figured we'll do through the
stream is first part of the stream I'll
just go through how I implemented it and
it was it was so easy I don't know why I
thought it was gonna be more difficult
than this but I'll run through how I
implemented it and of course I'll answer
any questions about it then I want to
demo another react project that I'm
almost finished with so I just have just
like one or two like tiny bugs that I
need to fix but basically is completely
functional so I want to demo that for
you that's the the react project I was
working on for that Udacity nano degree
and then after that we'll do our normal
question and answer session and then
we'll finish up so
I wish I had I had already scheduled the
stream before I knew that I would have
to be out of here around 3:00 so
otherwise I would have scheduled the
stream earlier but it I think it worked
out so let's get to it let me show you
first of all I'll show you what it looks
like so you can see you know we have we
have tabs now so just to give you an
idea of what it what it did look like if
you don't remember let me pull it over
from the other screen so this is what we
had so we didn't if it wasn't really
tabs it was just kind of like a menu
there was nothing nothing to indicate
what tab you were actually on so I think
we had talked about changing these at
some point but I never got around to it
so now not only does it look more like
material design should look I mean
normally you wouldn't have this many
tabs but you know we're kind of stuck
with this many categories right now I
was able to remove one category but now
there's actually an indication of what's
happening so you have this little
underline so I think that's nice and
also by default it defaults to the
franciscans before we had the default to
all but I talked to one of the designers
so the graphic designers and he thought
it was a little bit confusing to have
all of the logos right there and they
were kind of intermixed so they thought
this might be a better better way to
start out and now that we have an
indicator it makes more sense so users
can still get all over
you know once but now it's just not
quite as many you're right away so
that's what we've well that's what I've
done today among other things and this
is actually you can see I'm on the live
version of this site so if you want to
check it out it's our C dot Franciscan
University slash logos so you can check
that out I think this is going to go
it's going to go live you know obviously
it's already live in the sense that it's
available online but I'm I'm actually
gonna link to it for university
employees on Monday so think I've got
you know all the major things completed
I just tested out both the forms on the
live version they were going where they
were supposed to go all the data I
probably I think the only thing I want
to do is set up some sort of backup for
the data so it may end up just being a
Google sheet that gets populated but I'm
open to other ideas so if anybody has an
idea for a way for there to be a backup
of all the form data that gets sent so I
just need you know the info from the
fields somewhere in some other place
other than just being sent by email and
being sent to the project management
system so if you all have any ideas of
something that's really kind of
lightweight easy to implement let me
know otherwise I'm just going to send it
to a Google sheet and that'll help our
project manager out a lot just to be
able to double-check have a backup to
tell if you know maybe some slip through
the cracks
or just to get some data it's a lot
easier to look at a Google sheet and see
how many people requested what services
then to try to go through our project
management system so alright so let me
check the live chat just quickly there's
some some of you saying hi hey everyone
santosh says I love the material design
good I'm glad glad you liked it
gee CPR says the logo designs look great
awesome I'm glad you
like I can't take credit for them our
graphic designers they don't hide
skillful mess says congrats on 100k and
200k thank you thank you yeah we got if
you haven't seen the video already check
out the video Quincy put out earlier in
the week and it's we got a silver play
button from from Google so really cool
you get that when you pass up a hundred
thousand subscribers rollin says you
could add it to sequel light database
harsh it says firebase from back up okay
cool I'll look into those I'd like to
get implemented as soon as I can but
actually I'm interested in firebase I've
had a few people recommend it to me so
I'll check those out all right well let
me let me get to the code now so I think
the easiest way to do this is just going
to be to bring up github just to see the
difference so obviously right I I added
to our package JSON because you know we
get if you tried to download this
project you know we get like warnings
and stuff are our linter won't work if
we have things basically functions that
we're using that we haven't declared so
anyway that's all this is I just added
it to the the package JSON it's just yet
another thing to ignore and so I've
added a handle of tab change which it
just simply changes the state so not
really a big deal before I was changing
the state like right inside the render
but I vaguely remember someone saying at
some point that you shouldn't do it like
that so I pulled it out into this handle
that change function all right so that's
that's just basic stuff this is where
the change actually happened so let me
show you here's what we had before so we
had a ul with Li so each each menu item
was an Li so basically we just had a
click handler that when you clicked on
it it was setting this the active tab
you know based on whatever that value
was the tab key and then that would
change which you saw in terms of logos
now the problem when I initially looked
at the tabs from material UI and why I
thought it would take a long time is so
check this up so the way these tabs work
or you have your tab but then within the
tab you have markup and this is what
gets displayed when you change tabs so I
thought that's not gonna work with what
we're doing right because we were using
a masonry component and filtering things
right so I thought that it's just going
to be way too much work to redo
everything like this but when I started
to get into it earlier today I thought
maybe it's worth a shot to just leave
this out and see if we can put the click
you know the click handler here where we
have this on change and see what what
happens see if that would work and it
actually did work and that's why I was
able to get it done you know so quickly
it was like less than 20 minutes and I
will here in my code go here we go so
here's what I ended up doing and it
actually is you know even you know more
concise so that ul now becomes the tabs
component are what used to be our click
handler now becomes the on change and
then instead of changing the state here
we just call this handle tab change and
we change the state up there okay so
we're passing it right the value from
this from tabs and then we're setting
the state of active tab to that value
and then here we're adding instead of an
L is we're adding tabs and then we
simply took the same thing that we had
you know we had on tabs right we were
put inserting into this a tag tabs key
and I was giving us the the actual
display of what users were seeing in
terms of menu items and now we've put
that same thing in as the label all
right we've had it we have the same
value our value as is the tab key and
then we've just added the key right
because anytime you you know iterate
over something in react and have
multiple elements here you need to have
a key right so that's basically it and
and it worked so that's all we had to do
and because we already you know we
already had it all set up so that the
logos show up based on the value of the
active tab and state all we had to do
was make sure that when we click a tab
we change that value so we change the
state and that was it it works so this
is actually how it came up pretty much
by default the only other thing I had to
change so we had a little bit of space
on each side and that was because
originally we had we had all of this
inside a column in a row and that put
our padding on the sides there so I just
removed this from being inside a column
in a row and I moved
this name hide on medium and down this
class I move that directly on to the tab
so it's I don't need him and down and
that gives us the drop down so when it
gets too small you see it starts to get
really crowded here and then it drops
out and then we get our drop down which
still works I mean it just changes state
so that was it it was it was so simple
so sorry that you know normally I do
code live obviously it's that's the
whole point of the show but I just like
I said this ended up being way easier
than I thought and I finished it before
the stream started so if anyone has any
questions about how that worked or what
I did I'll take them right now and then
I'll do the demo for my other project so
let me just scan through the live chat
quickly
Zubair says suggestions continue this
project further with react native that
would be cool actually I really like
that idea I'm I'm working on a react
native project right now so after I
finished that maybe I'll give it a shot
at using doing this and react native
that would be really cool to be able to
tell you know users that if they wanted
to they could have this as an app as
well so maybe I'll give that a shot
let's see hi John handsome said and
react is supposed to be difficult for
the easy stuff yeah I've heard that
before when people's the Arak reactor
might's hard stuff easy and easy stuff
hard tea John says nice tab is a
controlled component you're lifting
state up yeah so if you check out even a
material you I so I went with I went
with the controlled example of the tabs
so there's there are different ways you
can do it but this one fit I think the
best for what I needed it for so yeah
basically the tab is a controlled
component and by that and correct me if
I'm explaining this wrong but normally
you have inputs as controlled components
in react very rarely would you not want
to have an input as control component
but in this case we have this tab which
is not exactly an input but it functions
in the same way in this case so the
value of the tab is based on the state
value and then when you click a tab it
changes state value right and then it
renders and the tab value gets updated
right so you're not directly changing
the value of tab with the click the
click changes state and then the change
is
they triggers a change in the value here
so that's basically what a controlled
component is and that's normally how you
would do forms so if you notice all the
forms that we've done they work like
that it's also kind of cool that when
you go when you need to work with that
form data you already have it there in
state right as you know it's already
there is an object so I I think it makes
working with forms a little bit easier
than normal but anyway that's that's
controlled controlled component alright
so let me show you and I'll get ready
for this so brace yourselves and let's
let's take a trip back in time and
imagine what it would be like if we had
react back in let's just say the 90s and
we wanted to make a blog with comments
and voting right so here's what it would
be like in my mind so so here is here is
my latest react project and I use Redux
for this
so with Redux we have a store and that's
the source of truth for the state
throughout the application so I did use
some local state for this mainly for the
inputs so that they were controlled
right
and I may have a UI element somewhere in
here that uses yeah actually I do so I
have some things that appear or
disappear based on the state and that's
best handled with local state so anyway
it's really basic whoops I don't even
know what I clicked on let me go back so
here you have post right here so post
title it tells you the author you can
vote on it so I can vote to increase the
score or do
increase the score tells me how many
comments there are I can delete the post
if I want I can add new posts so we
can't oops
actually I just saw something weird it's
using a different font here I didn't
know that I have to change it
and now we have our new post and I can
vote it up and you can see as I vote it
up it's changed the order because by
default it puts the posts that have the
highest score here but we can change
that and go lowest score first or we can
go date first so the newest first or the
oldest we can check out more about this
post so let's go to this one since it
has comments so here we have the post
here's the content the body of the post
I could edit it if I wanted to and if I
edited it oops
is it broken
did I break my submit ha ha I did make
some changes yesterday and then
committed them without testing so it's
possible that I broke it and I think I
did in fact whoa Fiona said 4:45 oh okay
actually I did know about that I just
think it's chance to fix it yet so
anyway normally you'd click Submit and
then immediately you'd see the change
let's see we have our comments we can
actually sort our comments the same way
so we can sort by votes or by date and
then you can edit a comment in line like
this the comments should work so let's
add something submit there we go so we
added it added the comment there it
could add some votes and we could delete
comments if we want and then at the
bottom we could we could add a new
comment so just add so now we have a new
comment let me think the only other
thing we could sort we have categories
so we sort by categories so that's it
that's my that's my project and if you
want to check out what's going on behind
the scenes there is
a Redux I get plug-in or something for
for Chrome what do they call them for
Chrome extension a redux extension so we
can see what's going on with the state
so here's how I have my state organized
right we have our posts each post has a
unique ID and comments also have unique
IDs
we're also grabbing the categories now I
have the comments here as well because
initially I did not put the comments
with the posts is it's two different API
calls to get them so I may end up
changing this so that it's not redundant
in that we have the same comment data
repeated there so once I figure out a
way to make everything work with that
maybe I'll do it we'll see if I have
time but right now it works as is our
sorting also this is in the in the store
so how we want to sort both the posts
and the comments is kept in in the store
so this is kind of a cool a cool way to
see what's going on so we can see let's
make some changes and then it'll show
you what changed so right now the only
thing that changed is that we we updated
from 7 to 8 in our our votes core for
that particular post so really cool
shows you what action was set off anyway
so this is my kind of fun fun projects
it was interesting the first thing I've
ever done with Redux so I've learned a
lot about Redux and that's kind of why I
went with this minimal UI I've been
wanting to do something like this with a
really like kind of old-school looking
UI and I thought this project would be
great because I had so much to learn
with
using Redux for the first time I didn't
want to get caught up in the UI so much
so this is very simple not that I didn't
put any thought into the UI it did you
undergo some revisions but because it's
mainly text base there's a lot of things
I don't worry about like like borders
you know it for luck cards and you know
what I'd normally do or worrying about
colors right there's all just one color
so anyway I just wanted to share that
with you all if you want to see the code
for this it's on my github profile so if
you check it out to get up its Jesse or
waggle its my github profile and then
its Udacity react nd readable so I will
be working on this you know so it'll be
updated but for now it's almost complete
and you can check out everything I'm
doing there's instructions for how to
get the the server up and running so
that you can use it if you wanted to you
know you could create posts and and have
it all work just like you know it's
working here so you'll need to get the
servers a separate repository I at some
point I may end up integrating the
server into the project so you don't
have to download two things but for now
it's like this I think that's it so
anybody have any questions about that
I'll answer that otherwise I'm gonna
take questions right now we'll do our
question-and-answer session and I'd like
to be definitely need to be finished
with the stream before three it would
give me a little extra time if we finish
before three which would be cool but
I'll certainly take questions up until I
don't know let's say like well actually
it's a different time zone for you all
so I'm not gonna say three let's say
probably
for another 20 minutes I'm good to take
questions so I don't know if it'll take
that long but it's about 20 minutes so
you have any questions go ahead and
throw them in the in the chat now and
I'll get to them and if you don't have
questions but you can stick around that
would be awesome too and then I'd love
for you all to help me answer the
questions and if you can't stick around
for the question-and-answer - thank you
for watching this was kind of odd that
it was such a short string today if this
is your first time watching it doesn't
normally work like this usually we get
at least an hour of real live coding in
before we get to the question and answer
so if you can join us for another stream
later on you'll get kind of the real
deal so alright let me go through the
questions now if there are any ok Harsha
did mention that react 16 is out all
right and that's the react fibre it's
also the one that has the new license
I think reacts under MIT license now so
and there's a there's other cool stuff I
haven't gone through all the changes in
the new version of react but one that I
heard that I thought would have saved me
some time and earlier project was that
you don't need to have everything
wrapped in a div so before I don't know
if I have an example of this so that I
could quickly show but before you would
need alright we can show it on here so
like in this return everything's wrapped
in this one tabs right but what if we
didn't want to wrap it what if we left
off the tabs and we just had these two
sibling components with no parent we
would get an error before but I guess
from what I've seen basically just from
what I've seen people saying in Twitter
you can now do that where you could have
two sibling components with no parent
and it'll work and you won't get an
error so I think that's really cool I
know especially when I'm trying to
convert something that's not
react and then make a react version of
it you copy and paste a lot of code and
you end up adding a lot of extra divs in
there that you didn't have originally
because you're trying to break
everything out into components and when
you do that you you need to wrap
everything in div so this this I think
will save time and be useful I don't
know about the other changes I've heard
there's some differences in the way you
do server-side rendering and it's faster
it's supposed to be faster than than
before so anyway so it seems cool I'll
have to maybe read up more on on react
16 so the next react project that we do
will most likely use react 16 and then
we can get into some more of the changes
but I probably won't get into the new
react project for a little while so next
week when I come back we'll probably be
working on project 1 again and that was
that catechetical Institute site so
we're gonna be doing some updates for
that
now that is react but it's we're doing
some weird stuff because that's that
uses some react and it uses some jQuery
so I'll be I'm interested to revisit
that and and try to remember like what I
was thinking when I did that but
hopefully we can improve upon what we
had before and get some things done that
we just you know ran out of time and
couldn't get done ok you go back to the
live chat John Henson says that looks
more like the 80s yeah
you're right yeah in the 90s like we
actually had I mean Windows was already
out in the 90s so you wouldn't really
see this my original inspiration for
this was the matrix you know where you
had the screen with all the green
letters and everything so that's where I
got my my idea for the green at least
and then I just looked on google fonts
for the most old-school looking font I
could find it looks kind of like
pixelated you know
anyway
okay Santosh asks Heywood rerender the
tabs also on tab change
let me see let's go back it it will need
to render in the sense and see right so
it will need to change right this this
underlined so I'm I'm assuming I didn't
look behind the scenes to see what all
is going on with this underlying and the
effect here so to really know I have to
look into what's material UI is doing in
that tab component I don't know but I
assume there's disree rendering going on
probably doesn't have to rerender all
the tabs each time but I wouldn't guess
at least the the previous like the
current tab and then the new tab that
you're switching to I don't know look
that's like kind of a little bit more
technical than I usually get with
material UI I don't often look into how
the components are made unless I have
two T John says awesome man I love the
terminal look thank you
actually my reviewers so I mentioned I'm
doing this for a react manner or at
udacity nanodegree and so you have to
have your project reviewed until it you
meet all the requirements and my first
reviewer really love the retro kind of
UI look so that was that was cool I was
worried I'd sent a message when I sent
it into review and I'm like listen the
UI is like it's a joke it's just for fun
so if it's an issue let me know I can
change it but they were totally cool
with it
uh-huh a boo now says okay I just found
where I belong huh so I'm assuming
you're saying you belong here if that's
the case that's awesome welcome
all right cool so thank you a few more
people are saying that they like like
the app this one how it looks so cool
glad you like it yes would probably
never make anything for real like this
it's just for fun but yeah I don't know
it is cool
it's like it's the Souchak you know
let's see okay I banal says please what
can you tell a beginner like me what
preliminaries do I need in order to
catch up I know just HTML CSS and I'm
self-taught okay well I think the next
step for you would be JavaScript so that
will allow you to do a lot more like if
you wanted to move on to react probably
should learn at least some basics of
JavaScript first if not more but pretty
much anything anything more advanced in
terms of front-end development anything
more advanced than HTML CSS you get into
JavaScript land so you can check out you
know free code camps lessons if you
wanted to or if there's a lot of places
that have materials free materials to
learn JavaScript so depending on how you
like to learn there's something out
there for you there's a great book
called you don't know Jay s and it's
available for free on github I don't
really have the link right now but if
you search for the title of that book
the whole thing is available on github
for free so if you liked reading that's
it if you like in browser exercises you
know go with free code camp or code
Academy if you like YouTube videos
there's a ton of great JavaScript
YouTube videos on our Channel
so bo Carnes does a lot of JavaScript
tutorial videos all the way from the
basics to more advanced stuff and then
there's a lot of other YouTube channels
that have tutorials as well so so check
that out and then you can always you
know come in to live chat when I'm
streaming and ask any questions that you
want or you can you know send me a send
me message on Twitter or something I'd
be happy to help you out as much as I
can Alexander says just to send love and
I'm on my way to work well awesome I
have a great day at work thanks for
stopping in let's see John B says I
can't share the link but search in
Google github free programming books and
the first link or second link has all
sorts of free books including you don't
know J s alright cool thank you for that
John B alright so yeah I'm really glad
that we could help let's see oh one more
thing I want to say before I wrap things
up and if you if someone puts in another
question I'll answer that as well but
this is totally not programming related
but it may help you with your
programming so if you like to listen to
music while you while you code I just
found out I got an email from Spotify
about a new playlist that they have and
it's called your time capsule and so
they I don't know how they've figured
out I mean maybe they have my age but
somehow they figured out like what time
period would be nostalgic for me
so they've suggested all these nineties
songs for me and so far the playlist is
is pretty spot-on in terms of songs that
I did listen to back in the day and that
I still like so so I don't know about
you but I'm always looking for new music
yeah sometimes it's a struggle to find
new things you know so long just get old
after a while so anyway check that out
the your time
so playlist I don't know I think the
right music can really help you be
productive when you're coding so see me
check that out okay at E John says what
was the biggest challenge with learning
Redux probably I'm like figuring out how
to organize the state like so this the
store so in the class I was taking it
said like you should figure out how you
want to structure your store first and I
didn't really know enough that I felt
comfortable doing that so I started
doing the project and then I had to
restructure the store you know like
several times before I got it to the
point you know where it's like this so
that was frustrating for me that I had
to constantly keep changing my reducers
and then my actions accordingly to
restructure this store and so I got it
to this point where a lot of all my post
stuff is here and then each view is
pulling from here and then when
something updates it updates
automatically in every view you know
which is the whole point of Redux but
coming from a place where like each
component has their own state and you
might have a parent component so you
could share state it was it was weird
it was definitely different so it just
it's what we want to get used to that
idea of like you're not directly
changing things you know like within a
component it's very simple to say okay
I'm gonna change state it's just right
there you change it but now it's like a
roundabout way of like I'm going to fire
off an action and there'll be a reducer
and then the state will change and then
the store will change and then that'll
get passed down and then it'll get put
into props for each component and so
there's like this whole flow
that happens that it just took a lot for
me to get my head around that I mean I
know that's not really as a specific
answer but Redux is like it only works
if all the parts are in place it's
really hard to just take a chunk of
Redux and try to learn it you have to
learn the whole thing at once because
you can't just say like all right I'm
gonna learn actions well actions by
themselves will not do anything you
can't just learn reducers right you have
to learn it all so that was it was tough
to just get my mind around the entire
thing so there was a ton of refactoring
that went into it and rethinking
everything but eventually I eventually I
just found myself like being able to
delete huge portions of things to say
like alright I I was knowing it like
this but I don't need all this stuff so
it just took a lot to get down to that
it took me more time and I thought it
would but now I think I'm finally you
know getting it I would I'm like by no
means an expert right this is my first
crack at it so I'm sure there's a lot of
things I could be doing better but but
so far the reviewers have said that I've
structured my reducers you know well and
my storage structured well with the
exception of the redundancy with the
comments so I'm happy about that
let's see
I got some these new questions in here
Swallow says kulap and I don't know if
it is just me but I like the theme more
than others used for the editor at least
for presentation like this what idea is
do you mean this this theme I mean this
is the this is dev tools chrome dev
tools and with the redux extension and
it's just kind of like a middleware so
you have to tie this in when you first
initialize your your store dart says
what IDE would you suggest I don't
really use an IDE per se but my code
editor is Adam I also use Visual Studio
code I like them both
santosh acid doesn't help in terms of
performance Redux there's just plain
reacts I don't I don't know I haven't
tested it out myself and I haven't
really read anything about it whether or
not Redux is more performant than just
handling state you know within
components depending on the size and
complexity of your application it can
help keep everything straight reduce
bugs because you don't have like you're
not trying to pass down state through a
ton of child components and you you
never like mutate the store directly so
there's it's almost like there are these
safeguards in place so that things are
consistent in terms of the state you
know throughout so I don't know if that
translates to any performance increase
but it I it simplifies development I
would think for a small application to
definitely make things more complicated
than it needs to be but for something
larger and complex it can just simplify
the way you reason about it
t-jon says awesome job man thank you I
appreciate that
okay John B says asks if I know UML
diagrams might help in future for
helping map out how the stores should be
structured actually no I've never heard
of UML diagram so I'll have to check
those out
let me alright so I I just did a Google
search for that and I'm gonna leave that
up on my screen so when I come back on
Monday out it'll be right there and I
can check that out so anyway it's just
about the twenty minutes that I said I
would do for for questions so I'm gonna
wrap things up now thank you so much for
watching sorry that it was not a normal
stream and shorter than usual but still
got some questions answered and
hopefully you know some of you guess on
some help and a little a little intro to
redux maybe let's see yeah that's it I
should be back on Monday Monday
afternoon at some point or at least
afternoon in Eastern Time but have a
great weekend everyone and I'll see you
on Monday